let's talk about yet another suspicious
Russian death we recently did a story
about Russian opposition journals of
vladimir cara mirza being poisoned and
we also ran down really a stunningly
long list of other russian dissidents
who were killed under very weird and
suspicious circumstances and we were
alluding to the possibility that all or
most of them had not been sort of
accidental deaths and there may have
been a relationship between their
political views and the Putin government
okay we've now learned that on us
election day Sergei Creve of an employee
of the Russian consulate in New York
City was found dead at his office with
blunt trauma head injuries and his name
is just now surfacing for the first time
we're only now learning about this which
is also part of why it is raising the
eyebrows of many people and other
consulate employees had originally said
that he died from jumping off the roof
of the building but by the time that
emergency responders and journalists
showed up the employee said oh he died
from a heart attack so the story had
sort of changed at least potentially the
Kremlin is maintaining that he did die
of a heart attack and I guess the the
idea is and what the NYPD said was that
he had a heart attack on the roof and
fell off the building because of the
heart attack and that that's what it is
that happened the NYPD which is weird in
and of itself the NYPD then closed the
case before getting results from the
medical examiner declaring it a natural
death which is less than common usually
they wait to get more information from
the medical examiner but again by itself
not necessarily indicative of anything
the body was released the day after his
death to an undisclosed recipient the
medical examiner no longer has the body
all right that's sort of a little odd
but again we're talking about you know
it's a Russian employee and there may be
reasons why that took place by itself
not indicative of anything in particular
no funeral home in the area has a record
of him but again okay we're talking
about a Russian individual here
maybe his remains were sent back to
Russia for the funeral by itself not
indicative of anything but we've got
kind of a growing list of weird
circumstances here don't we you add it
all up it gets very suspicious and I
mean it's especially troubling because
we've talked a lot about these
mysterious Russian deaths yeah but if
this one actually occurred in the United
States in New York City on election day
we're both campaign headquarters were
and there were probably a ton of
security I mean it's just it's just very
interesting and it gets even more
interesting Aeroflot the only airline
with direct flights between New York
City and Moscow would not say whether or
not they had flown the body back to
Russia why would they take anything
other than a direct flight the only
direct flights available on Aeroflot but
they wouldn't say again by itself maybe
it's just their policy they don't
comment etc BuzzFeed requested an
incident report from the New York Police
Department and the New York Police
Department denied it saying you didn't
include the date precinct and location
of death but BuzzFeed's request they've
published it did include all of those
things and experts and former police
officers are saying NYPD almost never
with holds these reports from the public
so this is also sort of odd and a
government transparency expert told
BuzzFeed the incident report after an
investigation is closed typically that
is releasable it's really weird that
they would categorically state that it
was rejected incident reports are not
broadly exempt from public records laws
his name wasn't even released by police
until this week which is why I'm telling
you about it now rather than three
months ago when it happened State
Department and FBI asked a comment
they've declined Russian media says that
he was in charge of relaying secret
messages to and from Russia no one with
his name shows up in any public new york
city records indicating that he lived
there his residence address listed on
his new york city death report doesn't
exist of course it doesn't help that the
russian federal government is usually
involved in investigating things like
this but a dozen or so pad weird
individual little tidbits that by
themselves don't really mean anything
but altogether another weird situation
and you'd like to hope that our
intelligence agency
and entities like the State Department
and the New York City Police Department
are withholding information because it's
part of a larger investigation yeah but
there's no way to know for sure at this
point they could say that somebody could
at some point say this may be related to
an ongoing investigation of course we've
heard from the FBI they don't comment on
ongoing investigations unless of course
your name's Hillary Clinton and it's
like a month before the election in that
case then you can get two letters in a
press conference about an ongoing
investigation or even an investigation
that's been closed which is actually
even weirder discuss this with us on
reddit david pakman.com slash our edie
di t heading towards 3,000 different
viewers and listeners on our reddit
discussion forum I hope you'll join us
there Gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one Xbox 360
ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free 30
day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s